we started out with with the petrov
yeah it was
a surprise for us i'm guessing also
surprise for magnus although he did play
quickly and he had something in mind
but still he couldn't have expected that
yon would play an opening that not only
he's never played before
but that he he's never even played
similar lines like this before yeah it's
it's totally different from what he's uh
traditionally played but it made us
excited because we have fabiana caruana
with us in the studio in case you missed
that memo bobby we have fabiana carwana
bobby um and fabio karwana knows the
petrol better than anybody and the first
point that he made robert was really
that right here the move 5d4
was was either a showing of in hindsight
we learned that maybe magnus didn't have
anything because we've talked a lot
about the fact that knight to c3 is
probably where the more rich variations
lie yeah well i might disagree slightly
with that statement he might have things
in sharper positions but he hasn't
looked at them as recently as jan has
okay so there could be a fight for an
advantage but if you take a sharper line
against somebody who was just recently
looking at with his team of seconds and
his engines and all that preparation
that goes into a match like this then
you put yourself at a huge risk so he
took the safer approach no tactics
pieces aren't flying across the board
instead he said let me try to nurse a
small advantage if i can get one wasn't
meant to be yeah
and if of course we see a petrol again
i'll say i agree with with robert's
disagreement of what i said and that i
think we probably
i think we probably would see knight c3
a second time now that there has been a
huge reveal in this match which is hey
jan who doesn't normally play the petrov
well he might be playing the petrov in
the 2021 feed a world chess championship
bout we played a lot of theory here
bobby was predicting the main lines that
all occurred on the board uh stop me
when you want to fabi but this was this
was all theory here yeah this was known
to both players in general this is a
very known position and we were speaking
about it
early on in the game and looking at some
of the possible lines where white can
take on b7 with the queen and things get
a bit sharp and crazy yep uh but magnus
chose a different approach a more calm
one where he
uh yeah a more positional approach
rather than playing queen takes b7 he
played b take c3
well we'll we'll just show real quick
the one of the key points of these lines
everyone is that even though the rook
falls on
on a8 things like knight e4 takes and
queen d7 lead to tons of incredibly
sharp lines where this queen maybe
doesn't ever find safety again and so if
you you want to see the full details of
that either look up the theory or even
just replay the beginning of our show
okay b take c3 was played b6
yeah i think we mentioned after cd5
queen b5
uh after queen d7 white had two options
um one was the one move he played a4 but
the other one was to take on d7
immediately and this would have been a
slightly more direct approach and now to
play a4 and to
uh to play it more slowly
and uh
i'm wondering if
um
what magnus did was a bit too direct
okay and again a lot of things you were
highlighting as the battle becomes about
the weak c3 pawn versus d5 but again
what magnus did was the more direct
approach a4 robert
and we saw right away that jan was
prepared when the queen trade in a5 was
played and part of the reason this is
more direct is because it gives black an
obvious edge on the queen side this pawn
a5 is a protected past pawn whereas in
the other position with the pawn still
on a4 for white the c3 pawn is going to
remain a target no matter what but here
black has a second plus in the position
and that's the outside pass pawn so jan
knew exactly what he was doing at this
stage he was playing quickly he was
taking some time but he was playing
confidently and well and i think that a5
he knew it and he was able to secure a
position without any disadvantage
hindsight is 20 20 so anyone who's been
here from the beginning is going to say
wait in the beginning of this you guys
were saying knight h4 what a brilliant
novelty well and to be clear it was a
novelty this was the first move played
in the game that had never been played
before and it was that magnus played it
and then quickly played g4 that had us
kind of excited the long-term ideas
bobby highlight them in terms of what we
initially assessed as potentially
magnus's positional positional maneuver
here yeah i think we were super excited
when g4 happened because it's both a
very unusual sequence of moves and that
h4 and g4 looks like
the exact opposite thing of what you
want to do right like all the actions on
the queen side
but you're doing some stuff on the king
side weakening your pawn putting your
knight on the edge yeah but it was
obviously a deep idea he had um the
issue is that ian also seemed to know
what to do
unfortunately for all of us
it quickly turned into a position where
white didn't really have many chances
and i think tell everybody what the deep
idea is for white even though it didn't
work out yeah so the knight is rerouting
it looks like a great knight on f3 but
it's not really doing much so the knight
is rerouting itself to e3 potentially or
to f4 where it attacks white black's
only weakness in the position which is a
d5 pawn which is a very serious weakness
um the problem for white is that he has
his own weaknesses c3 as we saw was a
very bad weakness
and uh black is saved by this past a
pawn uh the position we got in the game
yeah as robert mentioned before this
past eight pawn is black saving grace
here
rook to c8 was played and it was so we
were we were jumping out of our seat a
little bit knight h4 and g4 and then
when yon played not just 97 but rook c8
quickly you noticed something what you
both did you notice i'll start with you
robert that okay
he must also still be okay because this
is a big moment which works should you
put on c8 a or f should you move the
knight to f6 first right so playing a
move like this quickly was kind of
revealing right it certainly was because
the way this position becomes the
dynamic is different it is level by
objective evaluation but it's not
symmetrical and it's not exactly
balanced black has its outside pass pawn
the a pawn white has this pawn on d4
that eventually started pushing up the
board so there are things to think about
for both sides because you're playing on
different areas although both sides of
the pass pawn they can march them a
little bit but not all the way and they
were able to maintain the balance
and and obviously after rook c8 bishop
before we
didn't have much else to look at and and
in hindsight again being 2020 we were
already calculating lines that probably
probably uh were the best variations for
both players to go for yeah the problem
from white's point of view is that he's
really forcing black's moves here uh if
black doesn't take on a four and take on
c3 he risks losing yeah so uh jan's
decisions were not too difficult and i
think we quickly noticed that this line
with rook takes c3 knight d5 rook d3
is black's best bet maybe rook to b3 is
is also a decent move uh and it looked
like magnus was a bit surprised by rook
to d3 so maybe he was more ready for
rook to b3
but it didn't seem like he could cause
beyond any problems in this position we
were already struggling to find ideas
for white here yep in hindsight
is there something to rook b3 robert you
pointed out something really crucial
about the rook coming here which isn't
just hitting the beep on it's that if
this pawn does make it to a2 there's
rook to b1 in a lot of positions
protected by the pawn
your thoughts on whether this could have
mounted anything i think it could also
land black in some trouble
because the pawn on b5 can't be captured
because there's always this fork on c7
so the rook on b3 it attacks the less
relevant pawn that white has the d-pawn
is what white's trying to push up the
board so there are some circumstances
where you give up b5 and just keep
pushing your pawn forward and with a
knight on f6 a rook on e7 like we saw in
the game this could be really dangerous
for black it's not about pond quantity
it's about quality black may be getting
a little bit greedy but white's pawn is
just storming up the board and that
could spell some serious disaster for
black all right well it makes sense then
again in terms of why young played rook
d3 here come the forcing lines rookie 7
knight f6 check you guys were already
pointing out that any time magnus wanted
it he would have a draw with 98 check
and of course the reasons there are that
the king can't really escape checks
without making matters a lot worse for
himself
in variations like this so
on that note we saw one repeating
then we saw a move d5 pawn is of course
poisoned due to the fork on f6 but it
was all at this point as you were
pointing out robert maybe just a magnus
bluff there was nothing to it yeah i
don't think it was a bluff but he's he
you can't win a game you've already
drawn and so magnus has done so well
over the years winning positions that
most other top grand masters would just
have agreed to withdraw 10 moves earlier
he is relentless in putting that
pressure on you and because he goes the
distance every time you can't let up as
his opponent so i think it's a good
decision because it's not just about
this game it's about the match as a
whole magnus is saying that i am going
to fight until i just don't see anything
left and we heard them after their game
finished they were talking back and
forth mags like hey there's nothing
there i'm just going to repeat the time
is now to make the draw but he's just
showing a little something that he wants
to fight whenever he's given the chance
to
any other comments on this on this
moment here g5 supported the night but
after a3 we know what we saw which was a
repeating of moves and the draw any any
last thoughts on something magnus could
have done i think that magnus's last
chance they were discussing d6 and this
is the most direct approach and um
it doesn't quite work out in terms of
proving an advantage yep maybe h4 would
have still been a bit tricky um
i keep mentioning this move and of
course it's not like it really changes
the evaluation it would still be equal
and i think robert mentioned a good move
in response h5 but at least it couldn't
have hurt him to try this and i'm a bit
surprised that he went for the immediate
repetition i think he he was calculating
d6 for a long time
uh
let's show one more time why it's
nothing special d696 d7 and jan
mentioned the rook d8 they're also
talking about knight g5 which might also
be good but rook d8 seems even easier
and here black has no real problems to
speak of
uh so i think magnus spent all his time
looking at this these kind of lines
and then he was low on time and he
didn't really want to
play a position and potentially take a
risk being low on time for the rest of
the game so
so he repeated which is a practical
decision under the circumstances
um
but yeah it it feels a bit like
um this is
overall this game is a big success for
yon a surprising magnus in the opening
um i don't know if we'll see magnus
return to e4 at least for the next few
games with white
um if he returns to e4 he'll need to
have something big in mind because i
think that ian is sure his showing his
intention is to play the petrol i don't
think that he's gonna be switching
openings with black he showed very good
prep and understanding of the position
and of the opening as a whole so i think
most likely magnus will try to probe in
in other lines in the closed openings
maybe with d4 maybe with knight f3 on or
c4 on the first moves well
you you already answered what was going
to be my final question is how should
the challenger be feeling right now but
you said this game that should probably
be seen as a big success for yon and his
team clearly surprising magnus and
magnus not getting anything despite
having white on the rest day
chess.com coverage of the 2021 feed a
world championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
what do you think
so
[Music]
you